Bíu kênh luôn, thu dưỡng lề mình hương yêu cầu các bộ ngành nêm tục tiếp thu các ý kiến đề hoàn thiện các dưỡng lộng
Má cáo từ chình theo đúng quy định đặc biệt, cần chương hoàn thiện các hồ xưa giãn chình của người tại kinh học không thường lệ giữ kiến giãn ra trong thẳng cám
Bà đàm tiến đồ, chất đường và hiểu quả, cho ý kiến về tương giãn lộng thu dưỡng yêu cầu giãn lộng kinh gióng mất độ sản xưa đổi
Bà đàm thống nhất, đồng bộ với thống pháp lột không để phát xinh các tụt thủ thành chính trong chéo trong quá trình chuyển nhận giãn và quan lý đất đai
Lối với lột nhà ở xưa đổi, thu dưỡng yêu cầu thề chế hoá này đủ trụ trương của tổ mi thư chủ tính nước
Về phát triển nhà ở xong hội nhà ở cho thế, nghiên cứu các cơ chế chính xác đặt thủ lột phá để phát triển các loại hình nhà ở
Các bạn thịt đỉnh về quyết nhà ở cúc già theo ứng tăng cường phân cấp cho đều phương với bộ lột hình xử dưỡng
Thủ bướng rao bộ công an tiếp thủ tối đa ý kiến của các chuyến ra nhà khoa học, nhưng kiểu kiến ghiệ cúc tế nhằm hoàn thiện dự thảo
Đánh giã này đủ tắc động của các quy định mới đối với phát triển kinh tế tuy nhân lĩnh vực gân hàng, tính dông, rưỡ liệu và công nghệ số, chánh tạo rao cảnh pháp lý đối với đổi mời sản tạo và phát triển kinh tế số
Chính vụ cũng thông nhất, đổi tin giãn lột đối thị đặc biệt, thành loạt phát triển lột thị, nhằm và nãy đủ phạm video trên của loại
Lối với định giữa ngợp nhất lột ngân xanh nhản lước và lột đối thị công, thủ dưỡng gầu rao sất kiế các quy định còn ráo thoa, chúng là đồng thời gian kiểu các kỳ đột phá về sự dụng ngân xác cho khoa học công nghệ, đồ mời sáng tạo và chuyển lối số, đối với hộ xời chính xác lột ăn toàn thức phẩm xe đổi.
Chính phủ thông nhất các chính xác lấn theo đề xuất của bộ ý tế trong đó chúng trong quan lý theo chuyển của ngấn,
cải cách phương thức kìm tra, để mạnh số phóa dưới liệu và nâng cá hợp qua quan liang tòa thức phẩm.
Điện quan đến các giãn hả tân chế lột, thủ dưỡng yếu cầu đánh giá tòa dạng dị dựa quả nấu tư tuy chuyển đường xác lọc cai hà lội hải phong,
bà đam sự dụng hiệu quả nguồn lực và phù hợp với định hướng phát triển công nghiệp đường xác,
đối với giãn đường vàng đái năm vùng thủ đo hà nội.
Cần lợi cho hình thức đầu tiêu phù hợp, cần đối ngồi vốn và nginh kiểu mở giọng hợp tác thủ tư.
Nhân mạnh yêu cầu đổi mấy mạnh mẽ thương duy xây dựng pháp lọc,
tủ tưởng định y các bộ ngành không để lợi của bộ, lợi ngành hưởng đến sự phát triển trong.
Pháp lọc, thải phục vụ yêu cầu phát triển của đánh nước trong giai đoạn mới,
tạo độ lực thuộc đại tăng trường.
Thủ tưởng cầu yêu cầu hạn chế tối đa việc bán hành khoảng nhiều người định hướng giãn cho cù mở nội giúp lọc.
Cần chương tổng gia só thể thống pháp lọc để sử li các quy định trồng trẻo,
mô thống nhất là trong các liến vực nước đại, đối thoại, đối thư,
sây dựng mối chương, đại sản công và phân khắp và li,
đông thời, nâng cao kỳ lọc kỳ cương, tiến mộ và chất lượng cộng tác sự giữ pháp lọc.
Khác cuộc chật để tình trắng trọng bán hành văn bản nướng giãn thí hành.
Không đề cầu tổ chức thực hiện trở thành điểm ngán của điểm ngán,
đối với 2,5 y địa định quy định trị thết các luật,
hị quyết của khu hội đã có hiệu lực nhưng chưa được bán hành.
Thủ tưởng yêu cầu các bộ ngành tập trung trị đạo,
sớm hoàn thành, chấm rất tỉ trắng trận bán hành văn bản quy định trị thết.
Không đề sây ra khoảng trống pháp lý.